اللواء فايز الدويري ما دلالات اعاده
استخدام المقاومه الصوارخ التي لم تنفجر
واستهداف الجيش الاسرائيلي بها كما يقال
الجود من الموجود يعني وبالتالي هذا
المتاح والموجود والمقاومه من خلال
ابداعات الفرديه
والجمعيه وعلى كافه المستويات توظف كل ما
يكون تحت يديها من اجل ايقاع الاذى
والتدمير في قوات العدو وبالتالي كهم
جلبوا المتفجرات حتى من من السفينه
البريطانيه الغاطسه في اعم ماقي مياه غزه
واستخد اعادوا تدوير المتفجرات في الحروب
السابقه وفي هذا اليوم اتيح لهم وجود
صاروخين كل صاروخ يزن واحد طن تقريبا
وبالتالي كانت فرصه ذهبيه لهم ان يتم
اعاده تجهيزها وهذا التجهيز يكون بحشوات
لاصقه وهو عمل سهل جدا بالنسبه لوحدات
الهندسه وربطها ب بكبسولات
وتعمل وبمنظر هيه تعمل من خلال التفجير عن
بعد وكان ال المسيطر على هذه العمليه لديه
من الجراه والاقدام والتضحيه والتاني
والصبر ان تصل قوات الجيش الاحتلال الى
المدى المؤثر ويقوم بالتفجير مما ادى الى
تدمير خمسه دبابات بمن فيها هذا هو قمه
الابداع ان ان تستخدم كل ما هو تحت اي
متاح وتحت يدك